[Music]
I'm Jim Latin I'm a professor of
marketing here at the GSB this is what
34 years for me at the GSB and if you
had asked me when I arrived if I thought
I would ever be teaching a subject like
Salesforce management I would have told
you you were high but it's been 15 years
now and that's what I've been doing let
me introduce my my kind of co-panelist
in all of this Mike I'm gonna say a few
words yeah so Mike smirk low I ran a
start a search fund in 2001 bought a
company called service source and I ran
it for about almost 12 years and now
live in Austin Texas where I have a
small venture capital firm investing in
early-stage technology related companies
okay great so as you know this is one of
three breakout sessions that are taking
place all of which are focusing on
issues that relate to either sales
building sales sales leadership or
something like that and I need to just
take a minute to reflect on the fact
that 15 years ago here at the GSB you
could not find a course on sales or
sales management anywhere in the MBA
curriculum we did nothing like that and
yet we have a conference now in which
you know an important slot in time of
the day has really been devoted to this
and frankly I think it was searched fund
folks and entrepreneurs and so on who
goaded us into doing something like this
the Center for entrepreneurial studies
students there kept getting this
feedback pay attention in class when
they talk about sales because that's
what some of the most important things
you're going to do and so they go back
and they look at the curriculum and say
unless I'm missing something there is no
place to pay attention in class about
sales or sales force management so mark
Leslie and I started this about 15 years
ago and I'm just really pleased at the
group that we have built up Mike for
example cooperated with us helped us to
write a case we've done a lot of things
with the CES case writers like Sarah
Sarah so we have sort of an opportunity
to reflect on some of that experience
what Mike and I would like to do
together is something let's sort of the
flip or the inverse of what of the
session that you just went through with
the C
Oh panel rather than spend most of the
time with us talking in a small amount
of time on QA we want to flip that mic
and I thought that we would have a bit
of a conversation for about 15 or 20
minutes and then spend the rest of the
time having the session essentially
driven by Q&A so this is my signal to
all of you that it's going to be your
responsibility to help us carry the rest
of the session right and I hope that
we'll be able to set up some things
that'll give you a sense of the
boundaries and the things that we'll be
discussing but we're gonna start with a
nice you know sitting down and chatting
with one another you know Mike and I
started by talking about this and I was
taken as I asked him about his
experience in you know kind of building
and scaling a sales organization I asked
him about his experience and the word
that he used that I grabbed on was
battle scars
I thought battle scars that's a really
interesting place to start and I just
thought you know it would be interesting
for others to kind of hear your story
you know what were some of those battle
scars and then maybe we can reflect on
some of the learning from you know that
kind of came from them
yeah sure well I would really encourage
start I'm going to ask questions because
I've got couple former board members
here and one company that I send the
board of in and anyone who knows me
knows that I can talk for about an hour
without stopping so I would encourage
the questions but um can I tell a story
I think you should okay however and by
the way I'm also good at interrupting
people who go back for hours so some of
my stories are entertaining I know
everyone's why billion can attest I tell
a good story um so I bought this company
with a great a wonderful friend of mine
David Kennedy who now runs serán capital
here in San Francisco we buy in 2003
there was one salesperson it was one of
the founders and we Dave and I'd split
up like most search funders our roles
and responsibilities and I took on sales
and marketing and so I spent a year
following one of the founders around
business was doing about five million of
revenue and learned everything I could
from him and he was migrating out of the
business and so we did we made I think
the mistake that I see over and over
again
we thought we need to go hire a head of
sales that's what we do almost like you
know my toilets leaking I need to hire a
plumber let me go look in the white
pages and fine or yellow pages to find a
plumber that's kind of the mindset we
had so we thought we gotta go hire a
great head of sales and so my real
battle scar the first one was um it was
July of 2004 so a year and a half into
the search the business was going okay
I literally hadn't taken a day off and
either David we had just hired our head
of sales and we went out and found a guy
who had run a big sales team and had all
the right boxes that you check yes great
sales person I even went to his former
CEOs house for lunch to do the the
reference checks that we talked about in
that last session or heard about so I
thought I'd done all the right things
and he had been at one point a really
good salesperson
he'd made a lot of money and then he as
we found out later the punchline is he
had developed some interesting personal
habits that we weren't aware of so call
it the first month on the job he tended
not to show up on Mondays Monday's were
particularly hard day for him drank a
lot of coffee he also had a but he'd
come in and he had band-aids on his
thumb where it looked like he had cut
himself somehow so we've started to
understand that he liked to party a lot
more than we had perhaps heard about and
I'm taking my first vacation this is
before the iPhone I'm down in the
Caribbean with my girlfriend now wife
and I get I'm walking to the lobby and
they have those old pink sheets I don't
any one here's old enough to remember
like here you have a phone message and
there's like five of them Mike you need
to call David Kennedy that's my business
partner Mike you really need to call
David like all day long he had been
calling so I finally call him up the
punch line of the story was it turns out
the guy we hired was had developed a
major cocaine problem that we had not he
hadn't had that in his previous
employment but he was arranging coke
addict and had missed meetings upon
meetings and David was basically calling
me say we need to fire him right now
are you okay with that so that was my
first holy blank moment as a searcher
where you go I really don't know what
I'm doing and I thought I did everything
right so that was the first story in the
battle so now I'm just curious is the
general
a lesson from this seeing people taking
those old yeah that's I mean you guys
want you wanted something you could take
away from the session don't hire coke
addicts there you go now I want to try
and dig a little deeper here because my
sense is that it does dovetail with what
we heard before about the challenges
associated with hiring is are there
special challenges associated with you
know sort of interviewing and hiring
people in sales yes absolutely if so I
mean I I think that we all want to avoid
the raging drug addict yeah that's
pretty good but the factors that are is
I think that there are some special and
generalizable issues when it comes to
scaling the sales force you're trying to
identify the right person with the right
set of attributes yeah how can we do
that with sales what's your experience
yeah and I would I mean the the quick
vignette to is I ended up firing two
more salespeople so we went through the
businesses going I did I messed this up
this is my point I messed up hiring at a
sales multiple times but the hardest
part of hiring a sales is they're really
good at selling and it sounds so
simplistic but they are naturally
trained to present themselves in the
best format and they are really good at
handling objections and they're really
good at talking you through how they're
gonna do things and so what we ended up
developing over time and it's a longer
story how we got there but we developed
a McKinsey like haste approach to really
flush out the natural aura of a sales
profession I think that's the number one
challenge assert especially if like most
searchers you didn't come up in the
sales organization so you haven't been a
sales person before you meet these
candidates and you think wow she's
awesome and all the great answers all
that stuff that's what they're that's
what may be trained and trained to do
their whole career right so if you based
on your experience now you know I have
essentially taught with a number of
people who were also sales practitioners
who have been you know thinking about
these issues what's interesting is is
that none of them that I've ever met
would characterize themselves as you
know that they have a high hit rate
I mean it's not like I say oh you know
99% at a time I can tell ya it's more
like 60 to 70% with sales professionals
no matter how hard we work at
interviewing coming up with case studies
and so on it's like 60 to 70 percent of
the time first of all is that consistent
with your experience and then second of
all how do you deal with that that kind
of success rate
yeah I mean my personal last minute what
I've seen personally and with portfolio
companies I think that's high not high
in the way you alluded to it session but
I I think it's I think the the loss
ratio or the miss ratio is probably even
greater than that 50 percent but I think
one of the things that I advocate and I
learned and I'm happy to tell you how we
got there is that you can't when I gave
the Plumber example there's often a
misnomer that says I just need to go
find a sales person and what I really
emphasize is it you need to go research
and figure out a lot about the sales
process so what is your buyer mindset
what what is the objections that need to
be overcome because those things will
then lead you to different type of sales
people hmm I mean naturally everyone
knows hey am I do getting a si am i
selling to consumer or am i selling to
enterprise am i selling SMB are am i
selling complex enterprise solutions
that's a pretty easy bifurcation on the
sales team the next the second or
tertiary level down is say okay but what
type of personality is going to work and
and what skills did they really need to
have and I think if you do that work
really going to first principles if you
will that will drive a much different
hiring process than most people start
off with most leaders like I did start
off with yeah yeah I so I wanted to say
how many of you are aware of the fact
that Mike Mirko has a blog you've been
there ever seen it okay so he has a
pretty interesting four part blog entry
on sales and sort of finding the right
person for sales and so on
yeah it's called and it's already it's
it's called sales leaders are like cats
and it basically came from a speech like
someone said to me is like I salespeople
like cats I just don't understand them
yeah
and so I take that analogy and run it
probably to death
but it's it's a long gated expose on
this exact experience at home and I
think that what the its kind of
interesting about the four part bit is
that Mike teases you through the first
four through the first three blog
entries to get to the fourth one where
he talks a little bit about the formula
for success and I thought it was
interesting because you mentioned some
things about mapping the sales process
onto the attributes of the individuals
that you're looking for which i think is
actually what's necessary to get you to
that fifty to sixty percent success rate
in hiring and not a lot of people give
it the thought that it deserves but
there's a certain task that you need to
have accomplished and in order to
accomplish that task you need to be able
to figure out who are the right people
what are the attributes that you're
looking for that'll get you to that
point where you're now screening out the
obvious mistakes but it's still very
difficult to get to the point where
you're going to be a hundred percent
correct it should not be something you
aspire to because the best sales
professionals that I have met in the you
know classes I've taught and everything
else they just accept that they can't do
that well the other thing I would agree
with everything you said Jim and I think
the other thing that I did buy so
literally we fired three head of sales
though you can can remember and the
business was growing 100 percent a year
so we're literally growing
year-over-year 100 percent we're firing
Head of Sales so something wasn't right
and I talked about this blog but I was
immensely frustrated because after the
cocaine guy then we tried to get sales
II guy that didn't work and then we went
got a BPO guy and it just it just didn't
seem it didn't seem to fit and so mark
Leslie who had been a great mentor mine
I wouldn't explain this to him he said
you don't it seems like you don't know
what you're hiring for so why don't you
hire a couple of different heads of
sales and try it out and so I went went
to the board and said I'm gonna run
sales David had David Kennedy had gone
off to start his private equity firm so
the business was at this point I don't
know how many people six seven hundred
people are something like that and I
said I'm gonna run sales for a year and
I'm gonna hire for bp's at sales and i'm
gonna purposely hire different
attributes and you
about a/b testing its scale if you know
what ABA testing sales this is like
really I don't know what the the closed
executive session was with the board
after I left like maybe we need a new
CEO I'm sure was one of the moms that
was brought up but I said I'm gonna try
this and we ended up hiring four
different salespeople and of the four
the lap number for the guy that we
actually didn't really think was a good
fit
ended up being remarkable and I would
have never hired him had I not done this
model so you know better to be lucky
than good or whatever the example is but
you know over the for three of the four
ended up taking different jobs in the
company one guy went to run our inside
sales team one became a GM one we fired
and one went on to be our head of sales
and did an incredible job first for
multiple years took us all the way
through our IPO so it but it was only
through that testing that we finally
said okay now we got the guy and then
once we got the leader we were able to
map the attributes and then build a case
study that said okay know what the
attributes are we know what we're
looking for
let's build a case study and let's turn
our recruiters on and that was really
where we hit in kind of the magical
scale part of an organization and so I
mean I just think it's interesting
because it shows up in the class that we
teach again and again this idea that
first of all you got to have a model
that tells you something about the
process or the task you want completed
and the attributes that you're looking
for yeah
but ultimately it also means that you
got to experiment with people right you
got a big people on board to the
organization and then find out whether
or not they're up to the task and that's
where you take that 60% and so on and
you begin to weed out the mistakes that
you make through there yeah certainly
especially when you're in a and I think
this is also one of the attributes is
depending on how mature the market is
are they're known successful sale is
there an organization in the marketplace
that has a great sales executive and
they're selling the same value
proposition probably little bit easier
to poach but if you're in a newer market
or less established value proposition
experimentation I don't know how else
you do it yeah so let's stop our
conversation here and invite some
participation from the group so we've
talked a little bit about
this idea you know I guess in them in
the morning they talked about these
steps to scaling and that first step of
scaling begins with people although
we've interjected this notion that some
reflection on process is important in
order for you to refine your
understanding of the person that you
need yep but from a sales perspective
we've sort of shared a few things here
what questions does that bring to mind
for you at the stage that you are and
your search process and let's you know
sort of open it up and take a few
questions I'll start over here and we'll
work our way around okay so now a bit of
process in all of this because this is
being taped and we're mic that could
pick us up but you guys your questions
will not be as easily heard so if it
sounds like I'm repeating you guys it's
because I am us just for the benefit of
the tape for later so the question and
I'll summarize it a little bit is what
do you do in sort of providing the
growth path opportunity for those who
join as sales but want to move into
sales management roles how would you
think about that so yeah it's it's a
it's an incredibly hard challenge and I
think probably harder than most
functions someone in the previous panel
talked about you know you as a CEO and
then your leaders and the growth
organization's job is constantly
changing
I think sales is particular hard because
of the very attributes and how different
the job is sales leader versus
individual contributor isn't just about
expanded scope it's a remarkably
different in my humble opinion expertise
needed so what I would do and I had that
multiple times is I would really tend to
sit down with the sales person who's
looking that career growth and explain
to them what I think sales leadership
cebause then talk to them about do you
really want to sit in the staff meeting
and hear get the update from HR
do you really want to spend your bulk
your time in Salesforce getting the
pipeline managing other folks and I
think there is a there's always good
salespeople always want to play any
other want to progress forward I think
it's pretty black and white in terms of
those who can actually move into that
role so I guess my short advice is sit
down and make sure they fully understand
what leadership looks like because I
found nine out of ten sales individual
contributors when they started to think
about the job they thought I really
don't want to do that you know I like to
go out and you know the really good
sales people my humble experience um
they like to win and they like to put
points on the board or whatever analogy
you want to use and that's very
different than what the sales leadership
job is so I've learned a lot from
teaching with Kirk Bowman who's right
now running the parallel session over
here and one of the things that Kirk
says is that you promote people based on
their understanding of the business and
that is not the same as making your
number and there are people who are very
good at making a number but the fact is
that the people who can forecast well
who knows something about managing a
pipeline and account and a customer who
are inclined to work with other people
to help them succeed those are the
things that you use and if you did you
know one of these attribute to profile
differences what you find is that you're
looking for a very different set of
people then the question is if you have
the growth potential to want to keep
those managerial potential people you
know in your organization you need to
create the opportunity for them to move
into a sales management role we have a
great example one of the case studies
that we wrote for the class is on
Qualtrics Qualtrics took an inside sales
organization and basically grew that
inside sales organization and now have a
path for those people who want to move
on to the larger more Enterprise
oriented sales they can step into there
step into sales management roles but it
was a really interesting process of
architecture creating the organization
that allowed people to see the ladder
through which you would move and the
qualities that you needed as an
individual to succeed there okay now I
know we had a something in the middle
over here
so the question is about sales for
specialization do we ask one person to
complete all the tasks associated with
the sales role or do we use a hybrid
type of a model in which different
people do different tasks yeah the it's
a great question a harder part of the
question is scale and size of company I
think for most and so I'm gonna steer my
advice or insights mostly towards search
small to medium-sized businesses I
personally believe that early on you
have to have someone who can do it all
and maybe not customer success that's a
that's a different animal altogether but
in terms of being able to prospect the
most frustrating thing I see is folks to
say you know if a salesperson comes in
says I need a B dia I need a development
component
I need marketing component I need cold
calling that's that's an S and that's
what Oracle does when you're you know
thirty billion dollars in sales but if
you're five to ten million or ten to
twelve it is I fundamentally believe
that you have to do the bulk of the
activities in one job at this stage but
others may have different point of view
I just think that's and I think it's a
really good indicator if you have the
Sales Leader who starts talking about
all that stuff I'm gonna board a couple
million dollar SAS company and the sales
leaders started talking about that stuff
and it's like I don't think this is the
right sales leader so I will add that I
don't think you know that I think it
depends upon the economics of your value
proposition and I think that you know a
lot of times people are looking for a go
to market solution which is
significantly less expensive so the top
to bottom sales individual who handles
it all that can be a very expensive
model sometimes so companies that have
figured out how to do demo on the web
right I don't let people get this
information and so on I think that more
and more companies will be searching for
hybrid solutions that involve technology
that take some of the tasks away from
the Salesforce well you need the
Salesforce to do is it's often the
persuasion the closing the dealing with
the complex sale and what we're finding
is that you know there's a wide range of
different sorts of solutions and then
managing that hybrid structure tends to
be a bit more challenging but it's
necessary for some companies just
because of the economics yeah and I'd
say I mean think it's a CEO one your I
think the hardest jobs especially when
you're getting the job is learning to
qualify a pipeline and so I think when
you when you talk about these things
there's a lot of Technology but I think
the hardest part is just figuring out
the no BS what's the number gonna be
yeah and so I think if you can isolate
the tools are great but when I think
about an emerging growth business how
many times have you had I mean everyone
who's in here is running a company
you've missed a quarter I've certainly
missed a bunch and usually it's because
the salesperson was overly optimistic
and so I think trying to get when I say
that's why I'm more on the model of you
gotten really understand they know what
they're doing can they sell and they did
can they actually predict what they're
gonna close three different skill sets
yeah all right come over to this section
over here Brad
yeah so the question was around the
watch out rate is there a better way to
do it and to be clear I actually think
the 50% is more round for a head of
sales I think if you're washing out 50%
of your reps you do have a you have a
different problem you know I think you
have a recruiting problem at that point
you're not you're not recruiting on reps
I mean I think you're at scale I think
you should be able to get to 70% would
be maybe that's too high but whenever
I'm helping with sales forecasting I'm
ok you got 10 reps 70% are gonna make
quota is usually what I would hope to be
at a best practice and 30% aren't gonna
make it and doesn't mean you wash them
out but I think your other question is a
really good one so service horse was we
started with 1 inch outside salesperson
we ended up when I when I moved to
chairman with about 50 or 60 people in
the outside sales function we also had
an inside sales team that went from 30
to almost 3,000 by the time over the
time I ran the business on it so the two
different beasts I guess in my first
point in there secondly we trained the
heck out of both and I don't think on
our inside sales team we had no where we
probably had a 85 or 90 percent success
rate it's a different model but I'm a
big believer that yes you should train
yes you should do acclamation and yes
you should do repeated case based
testing for reps development either
inside or outside meaning like you come
in and you want to learn how to sell I
don't think thrown you to the wolves and
saying here's a list of customers to go
call really works it might work in some
industries but I think you've got
anywhere near in complex sale I just
don't think that
I think you can use them through two
tests and we were in a really different
case I don't want to want to overextend
it you know G but we would take a rep
and we would count on a six-month
maturation process six months before we
expected them to even start to get
meaningful outside sales outside the
meetings and then we had a one-year are
they going to make it or not but but
that's but you got a layer in training
and when I say case base you're sitting
on calls with them you're doing some
role playing with them in as you're
training them and then you're starting
to let them make calls and you hope that
they're building a pipeline by six
months and in our case we're hoping that
they would our expect them to start to
close meaningful business after a year
so I'd like to make a distinction
between that personal productivity ramp
of the individual sales person and the
sales learning curve of the entire
organization and the challenge that a
lot of you guys will face because you
are at an early stage of the process is
that you're still trying to nail down
that sales model you're still trying to
understand what it takes to create a
repeatable sales process and a lot of
times if you've got this high washout
rate this turnover rate it's not because
the individual sales people aren't good
it's because they've been given a task
which is insufficiently well defined in
terms of this is the model that we
believe is repeatable and it mikesblog
he talks about the fact is you got to
understand the basis on which you are
succeeding you know and then you're
gonna build an organization to scale
that opportunity so the big lesson here
is don't start to scale until you have
you are confident that you have a
repeatable sales model in place if you
can do that then I think you still need
to give people the opportunity to
succeed that's the how long will it take
a you know a capable individual to learn
this model and then be able to reach
productivity in the organization Jim
says things so much better than I do I
make you think right guys put my chicken
scratch down and hand it to you
oh so you know this this is a message I
think and I you know I have to give
credit to mark Leslie for those of you
who have ever heard him speak on a
learning curve it is something that is
an epiphany for a lot of people oh my
god the reason that we're washing people
out is because we haven't learned
sufficiently about what it takes for a
rep to have a repeatable process and for
them to be successful yet it is great
his I mean I referenced in my blog I
look at a lot for me I think what I'm
trying to emphasize is the risk when
you're a first time CEO or new CEO is
that you kind of go sit in my office
look at the numbers he or she missed
their numbers again I need a new head of
sales and that is a and I did it I made
that mistake three times the repeatable
process but then also get out of your
office go on a bunch of calls learn what
the heck's working what's not working
and then come back and had a higher
higher head of sales versus I think it's
just a very common mistake to say I
don't know anything about sales sales is
hard I've never done sales just go out
go on some prospecting calls you learn a
ton yeah I mean I think that's a great
it's a great lesson a great message that
comes through in your blog post and so
on for somebody who has the battle scars
of having hired and failed and hired and
failed I think there are lessons to be
learned and you can kind of pass that on
to this group here and you'll make your
own mistakes and someone but maybe
that's one that you don't have to thanks
to Mike smirk low or maybe oh sorry so
you know I learned his I she was pretty
good at it and so I kept trying to
outsource this is like my board was like
you're pretty good at it maybe you
should allocate it to spend more time on
selling and that may be another answer
maybe you don't need a head of sales
yeah maybe you as the entrepreneur
that's what you're really good at and
then you can hire around you for to
cover other parts the operation okay
let's come back to this side of the room
and see if we have questions in the back
yeah yeah so the question is is that
what were the criteria around not of
having unsuccessful hires I guess I'd
only had two sales
I'd say the mistakes I made were a
little bit of the delegation aspect that
I alluded to before where we were growth
and it felt good but I thought I really
don't know what I'm doing the sales so
so the second guy that we fired came in
with all of the I know how to do this
and he really didn't he was completely
full of of nonsense BS I guess you'd say
but he and then the third guy was a
prototypical like I know how to hire
sales and talk to all about processes
and people and all these things that
sounded again sounded right and they
were right they just weren't right for
our marketplace so he sure has been very
successful in other businesses but what
he just didn't resonate with our
customers and so what I would net it out
is even though the business was growing
quite successfully we hadn't figured it
out and I think Jim says it less we
hadn't figure out what we were looking
for to repeatedly hire great sales
professionals and if you look at a head
of sales your job is to hire trained
managed hit numbers and we didn't really
know what type of rep we were looking
for so we were giving his head to sales
hey here's you got blood budget to go
hire 10 people but the third guy didn't
he went hired 10 people and they were
all kind of liked him and they didn't
work in our marketplace they didn't
resonate with our customers so that's
when we had to wipe it out but my real
learning is is just for the head of
sales to think about what is the what
does the individual contributor look
like how can you build processes to
replicated that as fast as possible and
that really starts with again knowing
your audience knowing your customer base
and it is it's an expensive mistake to
make because when you turn over the head
of sales you turn over about 50%
your sales organization and we turn over
50% of the sales organization now you've
got 50% of people who are starting at
the bottom of that personal productivity
curve again and so you know I've looked
at case studies in which as companies go
through the turmoil of trying to find
the person you watch the sales
organization go like this it's like I'm
back to zero again I'm back to zero
again and so it leads to the old three
envelopes joke which I won't tell but
it's you know yeah anyone's heard that
joke it's heard the three envelope joke
now you have to tell us yeah well new
CEO I'll do it quickly new CEO walks
into the desk is sit the former CEO says
I'm hey you know what I put three
envelopes in your drawer and every time
you have a really bad board meeting and
things aren't going well go to the door
and open the envelope okay so first bad
misses his quarter goes open opens
envelope it says restructured of the
organization I announce the big
restructuring organization come on
Slater couple of chords later misses the
second quarter goes pulls out the second
envelope higher the head of set fire the
head of sales does that and this is a
couple more quarters goes open up the
third envelope and the third envelope
says take out a pen and get three
envelopes I know but you know when you
hire a head when you fire a head of
sales is that the moral the stories when
you fire a head of sales no I did you
lose all the reps but you put the
organization probably a year back
because then you got to start everything
over so it is yeah question
so question is you have somebody who
runs counter to everything that your
company stands for in terms of culture
but hits this number is the only guy
who's hit his number do you get rid of
him or not
absolutely and we did it we did it we
had a guy that of audience participation
for a second how many of you in hearing
this and sort of thinking about your
role would say yeah the guy's got to go
raise your hand if you think the guy's
got to go how many think ya think no I
would not get rid of this guy because
your encounter and how many area of you
are not sure yeah okay so there'd be a
few people who are not sure but you know
doubt my doubt it was to me it was a
cultural issue we had a very good
example exact thing we had an individual
tumor as we're struggling through this
one guy who was making his numbers and
driving a big part of business and did
some things that were they weren't it
wasn't the coke guy that was an easy one
but it was just he wasn't a cultural fit
was doing a lot of things that were
disruptive and we made a difficult
choice to fire and a lot of my leaders
to this day that worked for me would
still say that was a seminal moment the
company because what it showed was that
we as a leadership team or not we were
we were set upon building a great
culture and I think that's you know I
can't answer in your particular
situation but I think as a leader you
will have these moments where you'll say
what's acceptable and it doesn't matter
if it's if you make an exception then
you'll make another exception I guess so
in the morning session I thought Chris
made a really good point he said what I
try to do is I try to envision where I
want to be and I work backwards from
there so now the question is where do
you want your organization to go my
sense is that the path to there doesn't
lead through this individual he's
keeping you from I mean unless your
vision for the future involves this guy
then I think that he
holding you back he's you know he's
undermining the culture which I think
the point was made really effectively
this morning that that is the most
important thing in terms of you are
being able to get people on board to
join your mission to help you accomplish
that vision so if he's in the way of
that yes it's really hard in the short
term but I think that's what you have to
do
how about here in the back yes the
question is where we were and when we
made that decision it was early it was
not at scale it was a big decision let's
put it that way and in a board level
like this is the one guy and I remember
he's like this you're gonna fire him the
number one rep so we were probably
number one I have seven or eight reps
that we had so it was a big decision
also but it doesn't add enough it gives
you a chance to go then fill the gap
yourself you know what if the guys
cutting corners
you know ethically and so on there are
little issues and so on but you got that
obligations you got a whole bunch of
people that you're you know we're
counting on you for the company to
continue so they can continue to be
employed and so on I appreciate you
helping us to put this closer to the
knife edge in terms of an ethical
dilemma however there's no sales leader
that I've ever talked to in the context
of my class who wouldn't say as soon as
you make a compromise that undermines
the trust in the organization you are
dead you are dead I mean you've lost all
of those things that you're trying to
build there so those are all really hard
things to address but I would encourage
you to think about how am I going to
address them after we get rid of this
guy who's poisoning the culture of the
organization yeah okay now this side
over here yeah
so just to repeat you know the question
for the camera we're talking about two
different styles of sales leadership one
of which is a little bit more friendly
and team-building and so on but less in
terms of accountability and performance
the other very high discipline the high
accountability but people just aren't as
happy in those working in that context
what do you do then yeah it's a really
tough question and you know it's like 1a
1b and guess if I had to that's the only
I can force myself to answer the
question it's like the interview
question I always ask is art are you
here where are you a great leader
because you work harder you're smart
right there's no right answer but you're
gonna want to get a flavor of it I would
have to go with accountability in 1a I
just think if you don't if you have an
organization and you don't want a jerk
and you forgot if the guy or gal is not
a great leader that's a different
conversation but I think in that
particular discipline like Moses if you
don't have accountability it's hard to
build you know it's it's building a
house on a sand if you will because
you're always gonna be in a situation
where you don't really know it certainly
as a CEO but the numbers are going and
that that to me is the hardest part
about it so I would say if you had to go
1a 1b I'd go accountability we had CEOs
this morning talk about the importance
of their role in developing their team
and I don't think there's any you know
necessarily any executive relationship
that is
any closer than head of sales and CEO in
the organization and so I do think that
one of the reflections you'd say is so
you know women thing could be coached I
mean if I had a without B or B without a
then a question is which could I
influence as somebody who is a partner
to this organization and I do think that
you play that role as coach and I don't
think you want to tell sales how to do
their job but I do think you want to say
we're in this together to create a high
performance organization I'm concerned
that we have people leaving what are
your thoughts on this how are we going
to move in that direction so I know that
Peter Kelly seemed to give the
impression of that you know you guys
there's so much promise in what you're
doing that great people will beat a path
to your door as a marketer I tend to
never believe that I never believe that
the better mousetrap is going to lead
those people to me so the question is
the people who you find who have
potential and promise which are the ones
that are coachable in the right
direction and I wonder whether or not it
might be easier to coach the guy who can
establish accountability into one where
you say I want people to feel like they
are valued within this organization and
not tortured within it that might I
don't know for sure but I would say you
probably have the information to help
you make that decision I'll swing back
over to this side over here
okay so question is what would a
playbook look like for scaling the sales
organization for a new business from day
1 to year 5 yeah I think well there's a
lot of great folks here that have done
the entrepreneurial the search to add to
this and maybe we can make that audience
participation I would my quick answer is
I would do two things I would go see as
many customers and prospects as I could
so to make my own assessment which
sounds obvious but often and when you're
you know we all know when I bought a
business you suddenly you know you go
from sitting in an office calling cold
calling companies to now you're running
a company and it's your first time like
it was for me you really don't know what
you're doing so I my advice is to go out
to see as many prospects and customers
and then secondarily I would try and
find to the example here we had earlier
if you have one good individual
contributor who's actually hitting the
numbers and when we bought service
source I was incredibly lucky on
multiple levels but we had one of the
founders who was really good and I just
followed him around
and so I would say like as a playbook
I'm not sure I have a elongated answer
but if you one out and see the customers
and prospects but - yeah one guy or gal
who's really good just hover around them
for probably I did it for a year and
from there you'll learn a tremendous
amount and I think that's you know of
all the things you have to do when you
first buy a business and maybe you could
argue the most valuable thing to do so I
don't know if that I mean your question
was more extended than that and I don't
know if there's other than the audience
that have a perspective on it but that
would be my 30 to 60 day approach I
guess yeah I mean that then you're
getting into the complexity of the
question becomes at five years I would
just caveat and say okay what scale are
you talking about are you you know are
you thirty sales people are you
international there's a bunch of aspects
that probably wastes a lot of time going
on but I think yeah I guess I would say
it depends I don't know so it's it's
it's hard to think about I mean I I'm
not aware of anybody who has written
this playbook right so I would say that
what I would tell the CEO to expect
between day 1 and year 5 is that you're
probably not going to do
with the same individual so this is a
learning curve function but the fact of
the matter is is that on day one you're
trying to do what what Mike suggested is
I'm looking for the repeatable scales
mesquita the repeatable sales model and
I haven't learned it yet and so I'm
going to deploy resources and I'm going
to get people incentive to discover what
it takes to succeed in finding our
target customers in selling right when I
get to that point and I start to have
some success you sort of think of that
as traction it is unlikely that the
person you have who's running around and
talking to customers and everything else
is going to be the one who will then put
a factory in place to allow you to
replicate this sales model over and over
again and sometimes people grow into
that role but sometimes they don't and
so the art for the CEO is to help people
to understand what role they're going to
play and they're going to be comfortable
in and each stage of this process and
maybe helping people to understand when
they're gonna step out when they're
gonna help you find the next person and
so on I can't tell you how many cases
that we've looked at in sales
organizations where the guy who started
things out is not the guy who helped
bring that that organization to scale
the mistake you'd make is you say we got
to be at scale in five years oh no could
be one year could be ten years you know
it's gonna take you a while to sort of
figure that out so the other thing I
would say is don't get hamstrung to the
playbook you start here and say the
first thing we have to do is figure out
what our repeatable scale scale sales
model is when we've got that come back
to me and talk about some of the next
steps I think it's pretty good I mean
it--one things I learned and I didn't do
raise it I think that's a good advice
for all leadership positions in sales
it's why the best example but there are
you know NBA teams go out and hire a
power forward for one year
and it worked to try and win a
championship or whatever your sports
example and I think as a leader you
sometimes can get caught up on this and
there are just great people that work
for you for 12 to 18 months and they did
a great job but your needs change and so
I think you know they don't want to
build a culture of where you're firing
people all the time but there's just a
situational aspect that says in every
function sometimes if you get a couple
years great out of a great individual
contribute
leader that's wonderful thing it's not a
bad thing happens all the time how about
here
so the question is having the head of
sales at I'm assuming earlier stage or
emerging growth 10 salespeople today do
you have the head of sales in
headquarters say preferably yes even in
remote employees I did have a head of
sales that wasn't near the end it wasn't
in the office and I just it never really
worked so I would make a strong early on
we made all of the executives be here
the company was here in San Francisco we
made them all worked and lived there and
we would disqualify folks if it wasn't
appropriate for them and maybe it scale
it's different but I would think where
you are now there's so much stuff
happening there's so much learnings and
happenings there's just there's things
happening that's hard to imagine that
important of a position isn't sitting
you know next year pretty close to you
okay in the middle yeah
yeah so so a question about sales
training I think it's incredibly
important and you know some tactics that
we did this is again some of the stuff
pre iphone days but we would even
because it was so importantly a small
group of target customers so we didn't
want to have a bad prospecting
experience but we would make them leave
voicemails to explain our value
proposition in the short voicemail
message internally we would make them
present to the leadership team before
they were able to go out and call cuz
every sales person says I'm good at this
I know what I'm doing
give me the deck in my list I'm gonna go
at least one my experience was so we
were very very protective of our
customer base and so we did do make them
do training sessions ongoing another
thing we did at more of its scale was we
would start to bring them to customer
quarterly business reviews just so they
could understand what they were selling
and we were in a BPO Business Process
Outsourcing play um but really keep them
engaged and then last but not least
overly over communicated so that I can
go on there's a lot of things you do but
one I think it's critically important
there's some very specific tactics you
can do and I think the hardest part
three I would say is resist the urge
that the salesperson is gonna have to
say hey I got this I know what I'm doing
don't underestimate how much you can
change the inflection of the curve
through good training sales management
process in which you inspect progress
towards quota on a regular basis there's
an expectation that you have a phone
call every week of a sales meeting and
so on and so good sales management will
be able to zero in on what if there is
attention
and deficit problems what is not being
paid attention to one of the things you
get into sales organizations is they get
into this cadence where everybody's
trying to close deals at the end of the
quarter and then they're desperately you
know trying to fill their pipeline at
the beginning of the quarter and so on
good sales management I think will help
them to make sure that you pay attention
to the right things you sort of smooth
that out and I you know I think that a
good expectation of here's the business
here's how we do this that's the you
know the role of the sales manager to
make sure that the sales organization is
following along those lines
one thing I'd add real quick to this is
us I also differentiate only sure I
almost forgot swing there's sales
pipeline
you know what Salesforce monitors each
stage we differentiate that between the
buying process which sounds weird but we
actually spent a lot of time on who's
the buyer who's the sniper who's gonna
try and kill us without us knowing it
what were this the emotional steps a
buyer had to go through and we would
actually track that with the pipeline
they're very different you know did demo
demo wanna go to contract that's the
stuff you track in Salesforce we spent a
lot of time on the buyers journey if you
will and then use that to monitor both
how our deals were progressing but also
what reps were what we were they might
be missing steps and that was being the
really fundamental training for us and I
think it's often overlooked as well yeah
absolutely it's wonderful you should
talk more but I mean it's a great thing
and I don't think and because especially
in kind of it's a compounds like complex
Enterprise sale we actually named the
buyer like Mary and it's coming now but
like here's what Mary does and and got
into the psychological profile and as
you said and then it can really change
how you can walk into meeting and also
change you as the CEO helps you
understand in a meeting like I would go
to meetings and be able to walk out and
go they're not lying because I saw Sam
over there who's VP of IT I saw his or
her body language and I know they're not
gonna buy like it just helps you monitor
the sales process really great advice
okay
I know it's different
all right so question has to do with the
role of the you know sort of mentor and
manager in the inside sales process no I
mean that's a tough question unless yeah
I mean we founded we would actually we
would promote similarly so on the inside
sales we would move to someone to play
our coach and they would actually still
hold quota so the big part for me what
I'm not sure this is the question but
for us we wanted to make sure it was the
natural progression when you're an
individual contributor then we move
until we hold team lead but the team
leads still had a quota so you can start
to see are they gonna make the jump to
real leadership and then we also we
moved a lot of people out of inside
sales and made them train the trainer's
so there's some people they're just they
kind of get the job but they don't love
it and so we would naturally be looking
for what we call train the trainer's
someone that could go train other inside
sales professionals so I guess what I'm
getting at to is you can find different
tracks for that the person but I'm not
sure if I'm exactly interesting test
keep them on a quoted not take away the
quad at least in our plan because and
then you could see motivation managerial
you know a bunch of natural skills that
you need to move on to a managerial
level okay I think we have time for one
more question
okay so a question has to do with
hunters versus farmers how do you you
know think about those two different
profiles I guess pretty simply I think
farmers don't have quota and they are
really good folks to help with customer
engagement I think hunters have quota I
mean I don't want to oversimplify it but
I hear this a lot and I don't really
know too many successful farmers in the
sales organization I have a little bit
different point of view but you're a
farmer that implies something very
different than going out and getting net
new and maybe it's install base or not
but I always found that there's the
farmer mindset to me is you're not
carrying quota perhaps that's
oversimplifying but I think it becomes
challenging when you start to think
about what's the role that somebody is
going to play so as we moved from
enterprise software to software as a
service the idea of selling that two
million dollar installation and then you
know essentially you get to eat what you
kill
versus selling something you know for
$100 or $1,000 a month over time as you
begin to compensate people in different
ways well okay so you have an annuity
now which will pay out to you as long as
we have this particular customer what it
does is the question of sales
specialization it begins to blunt the
your ability to provide incentive for
somebody who's really going out to look
for a new business and often I think
that's the difference here is that the
hunter is going to bring in net new and
then they're good at that you want to
compensate them extremely well for it
and give them the opportunity to move on
to continue to do that so that would
then involve creating a hybrid sales
organization in which you have a way of
passing on the customer growth
acquisition engagement and retention and
so on I just would I'm simple I I would
say you're they're shooting an elephant
in the old enterprise software model and
now you're just shooting a bunch of
squirrels they're still shooting you're
still a hunter but I think the
cultivation aspect is a very important
aspect of it I just don't think that's a
sales function right okay well here we
are we're at 12:15 right we are out of
time please join me in thanking Mike for
taking his time
[Applause]
[Music]